en allemagne le dirigeant du land de
thuringe appel à des élections
régionales anticipées il se dit prêt à
démissionner en cause son élection hier
suite à une alliance inédite avec la
droite nationaliste plusieurs
manifestations ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
autres mathilde de romagne en rupture de
digue pour le freitag la farce darfour
tu pour le frankfurter allgemeine
zeitung
pitoyable pour le bildt la stupeur qui
frappe les médias allemands et sans
précédent thomas ce qu'aimer riche du
parti libéral fdp a été élu président de
l'état de thuringe grâce au vote des
élus de l'afd le parti de droite
nationaliste et celle de la cd où les
chrétiens démocrates d'angela merkel une
alliance qui a fait l'effet d'une bombe
en allemagne et qui brise un tabou dans
ce pays encore marqué par le souvenir du
nazisme et de la seconde guerre mondiale
le président du fdp a tenu à prendre ses
distances avec ce pacte inédit le fdp ne
négocie pas et ne coopère pas avec l'afd
il n'y a pas de base de coopération nous
ne soutenons pas les objectifs et les
valeurs de ce parti même son de cloche
de la part du secrétaire général de la
cd ou paul signac qui a réagi sur
twitter travailler avec l'afd serait une
trahison des valeurs démocrate
chrétienne le parti entier allemagne à
fdr populiste et nationaliste
les vrais partis de droite sont lassés
des who et la cs ou circonstances
aggravantes dans l'état de thuringe
situé en ex allemagne de l'est
l'afd est dirigée par bjorn veut que
anti migrants et anti élites
il incarne la branche la plus radicale
de cette formation politique
deux heures seulement après les
résultats du vote des manifestants se
sont réunis notamment à berlin à cologne
à erfurt qu'elle pital de l'état
concerné les protestataires accusent de
l'afb d'être un parti fasciste
tu as cela montre simplement que ces
gens n'ont pas peur du contact avec ce
parti national et font cause commune
avec des gens comme eux que et toutes
les droites fasciste de l'afd lorsqu'il
s'agit d'arriver au pouvoir
c'est dangereux et c'est contre ça que
nous manifestons
ces dernières années à chaque rendez
vous aux urnes l'afd gagne des voix lors
des élections européennes l'an passé le
parti a envoyé 11 députés à strasbourg
quatre de plus que lors du précédent
scrutin